DR. SIEGEL, THANK YOU SO MUCH.
>> THANKS, TUCKER.
>> Tucker: SO WE HAVE
INTRODUCED YOU TO THE OWNERS OF
THE ATILIS GYM IN BELMAR,
NEW JERSEY, A COUPLE TIMES ON
THE SHOW.
THIS MORNING, THEY WERE
ARRESTED.
WHY?
FOR DEFYING THE STATE’S ORDERS.
THOSE ARRESTS COME AFTER A
THREE-MONTH STANDOFF BETWEEN THE
CO-OWNER OF THE GYM, IAN SMITH,
AND THE GOVERNOR OF NEW JERSEY,
PHIL MURPHY, BOTH OF WHOM HAVE
BEEN ON THE SHOW.
AT ONE POINT SMITH REMOVED THE
DOORS FROM THE GYM SO THE STATE
COULDN’T KEEP THEM SHUT BEFORE
REOPENING LAST MAY HE ANNOUNCED
HE WAS GOING TO DEAL
WITH THE CONSEQUENCES OF
VIOLATING STATE LAWS.
YOU’RE OPENLY DEFYING HIM ON
TELEVISION.
WHAT DO YOU THINK IS GOING TO
HAPPEN TO YOU WHEN YOU DO THIS?
>> WE ARE PREPARED FOR ANY AND
ALL CONSEQUENCES.
OUR ACTIONS ON MONDAY ARE GOING
TO BE GROUNDED IN THE IDEALS OF
CIVIL DISOBEDIENCE.
>> Tucker: HE SHOULD HAVE JUST
SET A FEDERAL BUILDING ON FIRE.
SCREAM THE RIGHT SLOGAN AND HE
WOULD BE FINE.
HE DIDN’T.
HE JOINS US TONIGHT.
TELL US WHAT HAPPENED.
>> FROM THE LAST TIME THAT WE
SPOKE, WE HAD LOST OUR NEWEST
CASE OF CONTEMPT OF COURT THAT
WAS ON FRIDAY OF LAST WEEK.
THE GOVERNOR SAID AND REQUESTED
IN COURT TO TAKE EXTRAORDINARY
MEASURES TO STOP US FROM
OPERATING IN BUSINESS.
THE JUDGE AGREED.
MY PARTNER AND I HAVE ADORES
REMOVE SINCE THURSDAY AND WE HAD
NOT LEFT THE BUILDING SINCE.
WE HAD TWO WEEKS WORTH OF
CLOTHING AND WE ARE PREPARED TO
STAY INSIDE AT ALL COST BUT WE
DID AGREE WE WOULD GO PEACEFULLY
IF LAW ENFORCEMENT CAME.
THAT TIME CAME THIS MORNING AT
ABOUT 5:10 THIS MORNING WHEN THE
COUNTY SHERIFF WALKED IN THE
BUILDING AND SAID THAT WE WERE
UNDER ARREST.
FRANK AND I AT THAT POINT WENT
PEACEFULLY AND WHEN WE ARRIVED
BACK AFTER BEING BOOKED, WE HAD
BOARDED UP DOORS.
>> Tucker: I HOPE THE SHERIFF
WAS EMBARRASSED.
I ASSUME HE WAS.
THERE ARE MURDERERS, WALKING
FREE A LOT OF THEM IN THE JERSEY
TONIGHT.
YOU WENT ON THIS SHOW AND YOU
KNEW IT WAS WAKING A FIGURE IN
THE FACE OF THE TYRANTS OF YOUR
STATE AND YOU DID IT ANYWAY.
>> BECAUSE I’M NOT AFRAID OF
TYRANTS.
NO AMERICAN SHOULD BE.
WE OUTNUMBER THEM GREATLY AND
THE ONLY THING THAT THEY RUN OFF
OF HIS FEAR WHICH IS WHY YOU SEE
WHAT YOU SEE IN THE MEDIA WHERE
THEY ARE PUMPING FEAR INTO THE
CORONAVIRUS WENT WHERE THEY
SHOULD BE PUMPING HIS SOLUTIONS.
THEY DON’T DO THAT.
THEY DON’T EVER OFFER ANY
SOLUTIONS.
IT IS WEAR A MASK, SHUT UP, AND
WAIT FOR A VACCINE.
THAT’S NOT A PUBLIC HEALTH AND I
WON’T SUBSCRIBE TO IT.
>> Tucker: OH.
[LAUGHS]
THAT’S THE MOST MOVING THING
I’VE HEARD IN A LONG TIME AND I
JUST WANT YOU TO RESTATE FOR
VIEWERS WHO DIDN’T SEE YOUR LAST
APPEARANCE ON THE SHOW.
HOW MANY INFECTIONS OF COVID-19
HAVE BEEN DOCUMENTED IN YOUR GYM
SO FAR, JUST TO GIVE OUR
AUDIENCE SOME SENSE OF THE
PUBLIC HEALTH THREAT YOU POSE.
>> AT THIS POINT, WE HAVE RECORD
FROM JUNE THAT WE REOPENED AND
ALLOWED VISITORS TO OUR
FACILITY.
WE HAVE OVER 13,000 VISITORS WHO
HAVE COME TO OUR LOCATION AND
NOT A SINGLE CASE SO FAR.
GOVERNOR MURPHY CANNOT SAY THAT
ABOUT THE LONG-TERM CARE
FACILITIES THAT ARE 100% IN HIS
CONTROL THAT HAVE BEEN SHUTDOWN
SINCE MARCH AND ACCOUNT FOR OVER
50% OF THE DEATHS IN THE STATE.
>> Tucker: YEAH, SO YOU POSE A
DOCUMENTED -- THIS IS NOT
SPECULATION.
THE HEALTH AUTHORITIES SAY YOU
POSE NO THREAT AT ALL, NOT ONE
INFECTION, AND YOU WERE
HANDCUFFED AND ARRESTED BECAUSE
YOU DEFIED GOVERNOR MURPHY.
YOU ARE A BRAVE MAN, IAN, AND
I’M GRATEFUL THAT YOU COME ON
THE SHOW AND I HOPE YOU WILL
KEEP US POSTED AS TO WHAT
HAPPENS NEXT.
>> ONE MORE THING TO END TONIGHT
IF I COULD.
GOVERNOR MURPHY ASKED US FOR 14
DAYS TO SHUT DOWN.
14 DAYS.
TODAY NEW JERSEY IT’S DAY 132
OVER SHUTDOWN.
I WOULD JUST LIKE EVERYBODY TO
THINK ABOUT THAT LONG AND HARD
BEFORE THEY SUPPORT HIS
POLICIES.